I knew I found the right gal and I'm  John Cena gets the sweetest surprise  from his fiancee Nikki Bella Nikki come  on out  none stop by The Ellen DeGeneres Show to  promote his new movie blockers which is  all about parents trying to stop their  kids from losing their virginity on prom  night prom night it's kind of perfect  after the actor admitted he missed his  own high school dance Ellen brought out  his wife-to-be for a prom redo so  there's a what we do I know there's a  king and queen and you're the only two  here ever will be clear all right you're  gonna be the king okay it turns out  you're gonna be the Queen okay the  couple even had their cheesy prom photos  down pat  that's good all right you have to slow  down because there's music and then  you'll slow dance  [Music]  we can fans like this better waiting  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]